so we're going to look
at the different types of training so we
have Kona that's one type of training
guaza another type of training and I'm
not listing all the different types then
o hkaa another type and then sparring
another type okay first let's just start
with kihon Wasa then and it's important
to know that these are different types
so that we don't try to make
in particular Kona every type of
training and therefore force it to
solve what is other types of training's
Arena of concern okay so just to refresh
everyone's memory in
Kona this is what happens so UK provides
the Yang aspect and then spinally
displaces per
prescription uh Naga then uses that
young aspect to generate their own
tanden field and to seize UK's tanden
field that is AI at the tanden at the
lower tonden does everyone here follow
me that's what's happening okay and this
is kazushi this is the seed of kazushi
okay and then from that Ike at the lower
Tom Den nag then reconciles Yin and
Yong you using a concentric spiral
rotation concentric means that this
spiral rotation of the yin and yangong
axis happens at a physical level an
energetic level and at a spiritual level
okay at a physical level the yin and
yangong axis are at the Yang contact
Point usually where you're touching me
pressing on me attacking me got itad and
and at the naget Uka Dynamic so uh
Tristan if you don't
mind okay is he is he pushes on here
here is the Yang axis here is the yin
axis and I'm going to rotate that rotate
it to get my uh reconciliation of that Y
young
Clash but my body and his body are also
going to in the sagittal plane spiral
rotate so as we stand up uh we have that
same Clash I don't ever stay here and
just move
my hands my whole body is going to move
on that spiral rotation so nag and UK
are also spiral rotating in the sagittal
plane in space do you get it
that would be spiral rotation at the
physical
component at the energetic component at
the same time not in a causal
relationship my lower tonden is spiral
rotating and concentrically at the same
time at the spiritual component my two
minds are
ceasing their dichotomous relationship
and I know it's weird but the usually
the first things you feel is your mind
is spal rotating your your mind spiral
rotate so for example in the last
podcast I mentioned that uh one of the
Poetics isqi you you're going to feel
the chi spiral rotating in you but you
know what if you feel it then you are
experiencing it and if you exper
experience it your mind is involved in
the experience and I cannot separate the
experience from the mind it's not
possible everywhere I'm experiencing
something my mind is there hence why I
said I had no problem if someone wants
to say your instead of your Chi dropping
your mind drops likewise instead of your
Chi spiral rotating your mind is spiral
rotating it doesn't matter to me okay
but this is what happens and so this is
what I do in Kon waza why because this
is the eternal return of Silk Road
cultures so um as these things if you
reverse it all here all of this spiral
rotation this reconciliation of Yin and
yangong returns me to the doubt returns
me to the moment of creation and this
this is good for
you not the undoing of this or the
manifestation in
Reverse is bad for you it it will take
its toll on you the more you have y y
more you have yin and yang the more
you'll have y yangong and the more you
have y Yang the more unwell you'll be so
periodically these premodern cultures
would have rituals and practices to
chill you the F out because if you hang
too much out in a dichotomous world you
will suffer you suffer you get sick you
feel pain you cause pain Etc okay but
this is the
point but you have to expand what you
might mean what I mean by sick and
wellness and all that you got to be
bigger than just what the world says
okay this is what is going on in kihon
waza okay in
Gaza you're still and this is iida well
to do
Gaza it's a part of iido so I still have
to do this to some degree especially the
ending part what makes it
guaza is not that I change any of this I
still have to do this otherwise I'm not
doing
iido
but UK does not have to do this
part depending on my rules it's not a
guarantee
okay UK could pull for example do you
understand and that pulling energy I now
have to use to generate IE
okay or if I open it up to any of kona's
attacks then sometimes you is striking
sometimes you is grabbing sometimes both
okay that would be guaza I'm not telling
the
Naga you have to do
this in the technique that I want you to
do such that you have to do this in EO
for a wrist grab what I've done is I've
taken away eel I've taken away the wrist
grab do you get it
but you have to do this still otherwise
it's not iido it's not Gaza there's no
you're doing something else do you get
it
okay o
henka is where in taking guaza where I
have to do this but I don't
prescribe what shape it takes such as EO
and I don't prescribe what initiates it
such as a wrist R for example but I also
say as I generate your iky at the tanden
try to get out of it that's what I'm
telling UK try to get out of it so it's
a kind of guaza oil hkaa go I'm going to
have a counter somewhere in there or a
repeated count counter
get out of it okay but in both of these
unlike the third one I usually work I'm
working with
konm I'm going to do I'm going to end up
with some variation of ikio nikoo any of
the pinning techniques some sort of Nag
waza or some variation on cute net
okay to me
this is different than sparring in
sparring I don't have to end up with
some version of a kihon waza I can
just kick you in the balls you your
groin is open I'll kick you in the balls
and you're done do you get it I don't
have to pin you I can just punch you in
the face uh I could put my thumbs in
your eyes do you get it's more open go
ahead and count
but as you can counter I want you to
counter with anything I don't want you
to just try to escape the iy adhesion I
want you to counter with anything and
since you can counter with anything I
will counter your counter with anything
that is sparring to me
okay all
right let us focus in on
Gaza and we know what we're doing here
ver kihon waza that's where I want to
focus
in in
Kona the teacher tells
me what to
do right and then I do
it in
Gaza nobody's telling me what to do okay
and I don't have to do what they're
telling me to do I can do whatever let's
go a little deeper
though if in my Gaza rule I'm going to
say Gaza from katatori okay you could
say Gaza from anything but let's just
stick Gaza from katatori so I told you
what we're starting with but I didn't
tell you what technique to do got it I
say you don't you don't have to do any
technique if we look at this
psychologically there in in
this I have
pre-selected in this case it was
selected for me but there's still a
pre-election to the doing
it a lot of times when people do Gaza
especially if the game has a rule such
that katat do it from
katat you will still see
pre-election to me that is not Gaza
that's just you picked the technique in
this one the teacher the teacher told me
but in this
one I told
me it's still
pre-election this is not g AA to me in
fact
Gaza is I don't pick the
technique I don't pick
it I don't want my ego tripartite mind
involved in this practice this practice
is about not using the ego tripartite
mind so you do not pre-select your
techniques even if you silently
pre-select them to yourselves
okay it is very difficult to do that if
you do a technique right from
contact if the person comes in and does
their little push you pick your
Technique it's difficult for the user to
go oh I picked that they're not usually
that honest we're not usually that
honest with ourselves but that teacher a
master can tell when the ego tripartite
mind functions and usually they'll tell
you hey don't pick the technique hey
don't pick the technique so a kind of
thing that I
do to get people where can you do this
and it's not pre-election is don't do
the move on
contact do some generic
deviation based on where and how they're
creating their young young Clash okay
and then usually what
happens the UK
wants to go
someplace after that for whatever reason
sometimes they're trying to predict what
you want to do sometimes they're afraid
where you're taking them in some way
you're going to sense what their will is
in that moment and that will is not
knowable until you're in that
moment I know everything before that I
know you're going to grab my wrist you
see that but you if you move out of the
way the UK will move into a position and
you have a will that shows up that did
not show up until
then grabbing my wrist was already
pre-selected by the rules of the game
we're going to do okay so I would do
this first is
deviate according to however they're
pushing then UK all UK react to that UK
reacts spontaneously to that because
they don't know
that they don't know how you're going to
do that and then so UK reacts and now
this is an immediate action and now you
respond to that okay here's where you
respond and so in a way you didn't pick
it UK picked it got it and UK can't pick
it again because the next time they'll
de you'll deviate a little different and
they'll react a little different every
time and so you'll have this is this is
the moment where you can start guaza
okay and what am I doing I'm doing all
this stuff that ended up down here well
in all of this stuff that is iido and
the only thing I have to do in Gaza is
not pre-select my stuff so that I'm not
utilizing my ego tripartite mind okay
there's nothing in what is iido that
says I have to go fast you don't have to
go fast I just have to spontaneously
respond with all of this stuff I listed
at that initial moment where UK's
unkknown reaction manifests itself do do
you guys understand that it's like a
it's just like when the Zen Abbot
would say uh you know
uh and now how do you react in that
moment that is is your moment of gu
right then how will you react will you
go oh wait let me think about well
that's the ego tripartite mind okay and
if you try to do the ego tripartite mind
in that moment you will always hesitate
you will always uh Yong Yong you will
always just to cut to the chase not do
any of the stuff that we just listed
below okay you will
not all right so if there's nothing fast
there's it's not about fast it's just
about responding to an immediate
response in UK spontaneously responding
then don't go
fast don't look for
any um big reaction out of your UK you
don't need that to do
guaza sometimes when you have a you want
a big throw then you have a desire for
the throw and now you pick the throw the
throw is pre-selected even if you could
even if you got the big throw you
pre-selected the throw you did that and
that's now not guaza you're not training
in guaza anymore okay you're not
training the mind all right so uh let me
show
you okay so I we all have different UK
you're all going to have have different
UK right and it does not matter the
ukemi skill of the UK to do Gaza because
what is Gaza try to SP rotate Yin and
yangong do you see that at the three
component levels
concentrically except I don't pre-select
when I do it got it that's that's all
guaza it's not fighting it's not
sparring it's not uh go fast and try to
get a big reaction do you guys see that
and so different
UK can do different things they can take
different levels of uky is that not true
okay so if I if I have this guy I could
check the hell out of him as fast as I
want to do do you get it but if I have a
different UK who what do I do then not
practice not train do you guys see that
no that doesn't make sense okay so we
have different UK with different skills
and uh uh which would you prefer for the
a grab attack what do you want to
do okay so we'll go to katat so here's
where I do that deviation and I feel
what she's doing okay I'll just get out
of the way here's another deviation I
get out of the way I just feel what
she's doing feel what she's
doing feel what she's
doing and somewhere in there she's going
to react to it and that's what I'm
looking for so let let
me I know you won't be able to see it on
video I doubt you guys will see it here
you might be able to feel it okay so as
I get out of the way these little steps
that she takes when she goes around you
do you see that okay so what those
little steps feel like is you push my
arm up if you pay attention do those
little steps just do the little steps no
do what you did do what you did do it
again good watch the top of her head do
it again you see it goes up so she's
holding my
hand you're pretending you're holding my
hand and now you do the little steps and
the Hand goes up you see that so that
would be my pressure here was my grip
got it and I feel your little steps and
I feel the hand going up do you guys see
that okay uh there's nothing I did that
caused that so for example uh just walk
around without a little prancing just
walk
around do you see that now do the
Prancing do you see I didn't do that she
did that do you guys see that okay so I
work on the pr so me pushing down on
that would not be a YY reconciliation so
I kind of let her hand push me up until
uh I wanted where where it's going to go
just cuz she let it go so what I mean by
for that she brought it up okay I might
use a bring it up but as I bring it up
now I feel her tension there you see how
she's going forward what does that tell
me she don't want to go backwards you
get that so again I could force it but I
don't force it I don't force that there
I turn it so she wants to go forward do
you get it go forward so we can see what
you wanted okay so as she wants to go
forward I'm turning it turning it ins
inside turn it
inside if you look it again we have our
hand
up here's our
cross right there it's very small but
it's here she wanted to go
opposite you see that go back she wants
to go opposite and I turn
it and
we're every time I turn the cross the
lower level
UK will have a moment of I don't know
where you're taking me do you get it do
you understand that and then they you
will you'll just fall cuz you won't know
what happened okay or I do the other one
she's prancing when she goes
up what did her hand do her prance for
me hand went up and in between prances
what' the hand do the hand went down you
get it so you can time that little plant
there up down I bring it this
way I feel what she's doing and I work
with that try to go
forward so she can't really go forward
because of the adhesion you see that but
I Don't Force It
I'm just controlling it at the
edge using what she's
doing so I'm just going to play right
now
try to go
forward try to go in try to go
out try to go
up try to go
forward try to go
back try to go
forward
so if I was playing with that UK I'm not
really interested in the throws I'm
interested in this connection right
here this I just like
this
[Music]
yes
but I'm not going
[Music]
fast
for
[Music]
speed doesn't have anything to do with
it just responding to her
immediate
yongyong crosses okay let's try okay so
in I think if you're going to get
totally out of of
the uh tactical spectrum of
kona you should be sparring instead you
have to do sparring instead okay if
you're going to stay within the Tactical
spectrum of
Kea then you can't do whatever
is do you guys understand you you have
to keep your your y energy going you got
to keep the Y energy going okay um just
don't make the mistake that guaza
wherein I'm trying to spontaneously
generate all that stuff I do in kihon
waza uh just don't make the mistake that
Gaza can take the place of sparring it
can't because it's going to whatever its
infinite
variation of final dispositions it's
going to be within the finite tactical
spectrum of Kon and we already know
koda's tactical Spectrum requires that
spinal displacement okay it just does
okay um let's uh
s uh when when I go again it's not that
I I can't just get out of the way and
then find something you have to find the
seizure you have to find the seizure you
have to be the one moving him not not
just him moving away I do move but I'm
moving him okay and then when I seize
his rotation his tanden I have to spiral
rotate it as well as F rotate our nag UK
Dynamic and that is always going to take
you into one of the kazushi
patterns so you're either going to do
the front inward or the back outward so
if I just he turn turn turn turn turn he
and I are not spiral rotating he and I
he is rotating around me I'm never going
to get into
that lean do you get it so we have I
have to be able to move him into that
lean you see
that and it doesn't have to be f
here's the lean
again I don't have to kill my
inexperienced
ukit
for
he's doing just
fine
I hope you saw this SP the uh
[Music]
basement can't just go like
this can't grab his head it's heavy
right now have to lower his
head then there's his
head okay try it
again okay even you go like this and you
go like that she's quite free to move
and because you don't have her her
Center you you're not moving moving the
center in and now you have these two
stay there please these two things are
working on her you add her initial
movement and it's even more you could
move her center around wherever you want
okay so you can't just swing your arms
it's not I'm not just swinging my arm
cuz then she just hits that and there's
nothing behind her so I would hit her
out for the strip okay you have to have
the center boom then I went to the base
okay
so can't go here hit her and then go
back okay if we were doing sparing uh
your range would be different got it so
I won't do it but my range stay there
please my range has to be here got it do
you understand so I can't be
here that's pretty much what would
happen in at full speed okay so you're
going to pop someone boom this Strike
should go there then her feet would come
up got it okay so as you're moving them
she has to feel that you she can't uh go
forward you see and I can always
project and now I do a two hands two
hands are doing it where's the energy
coming from the centrifical energy the
pull on this hand and then the hand on
the face together get those things
boom then you can do what you want to do
but if you just go
here she's pretty loose I can't get
anything this is all her waiting there
for me
okay feel B
together okay try it
again
the two of you must spiral rotate the
two of you in the sagittal plane must
spiral rotate you cannot just make a
circle don't pick the technique energy
is not going for you to pass that
[Music]
head his head's coming up so that would
be y do you do you feel that yes let me
in there please so you're you're over
here and his head's going up no no no no
no don't do that okay his head goes up
what do I have to do I I have to spir or
rotate something you get it something it
could be his head that I spir or rotate
on this
way so he he go he goes up and I spir
rotate his head this
way it could be he goes up and I switch
hands and I follow rotate this way you
get it cuz that was the Y energy but
this would be wrong he gets up and me
trying to shut him down do you get it or
he's getting up and me trying to break
his balance here I have to spir rotate
those things so he goes and gets up
right oh I let him
up you okay cannot Yong Yong the line
you have to spir rotate that okay okay
all right let's try it
again better going back to that
one
don't kneel down like that okay don't
don't use your weight we shouldn't have
to use our weight to do
this all right so back to the seizure so
I think you did one like this see
okay but as I come here here's
just where I'm touching just wherever
I'm touching you see and I'm not going
to bend you backwards I'm going to tilt
you you feel it feel it you see okay so
I just turn you around tilt you right I
I can hold you up I can turn you this
way I have control of you so going back
to sees the center here's where I'm
touching here's where I'm touching on
your body instead of just bending you
backwards and then go
in I just look for the control boom
control move
you okay or same thing on suou sitting
here and I just accelerate
[Music]
backwards I find where is your Center
where's your Center
boom accelerating you
backwards as slow speed finding your
Center
Center moving your Center do
[Music]
whatever
acceleration
seasoning of
center seing of
Center okay
[Music]
try
s